playing on controller is absolutely
broken and competitive for tonight right
now and I'm not just talking like ninja
complaining on Twitter broken I'm
talking like a MOT broken now aim assist
has been a fixture of competitive FPS
for years but I'm here to tell you
exactly what it is and how it works and
how it absolutely [ __ ] broke
competitive fortnight in half
[Music]
now this is the part of the video where
normally I tell you to LIKE and
subscribe and you should still do that
especially if you like fortnight because
I'm the only one around here who does
but we've got something new for you
we're streaming on Twitch these days so
head over to twitch.tv backslash to
squirt eSports and give us a follow
alright so how could it be that in
competitive eSports a controller player
could beat a mouse and keyboard player
for years controller players have been
laughed out of the competitive building
unless of course we're talking about
like Halo or Call of Duty but in
fortnight due to a mechanic called aim
assist well the controller players have
taken over alright I can still aim bot
with this gotta lower it again come on
bro aim assist is kind of like a magnet
when you're on controller you're at a
disadvantage as far as aiming and
tracking so when you aim down sight the
reticle kind of follows the target a
little bit just to give you you know a
little advantage and this has existed
forever but it hasn't been until the
last few years when cross-play got into
the mix of things that controller
players and mouse and keyboard players
started to be pitted against each other
in eSports competition and balancing how
aim assist affects that arms race has
proved to be quite the challenge for
developers at first in fortnight at
least it was pretty light touch you've
had controller players like Aidan and
Nick mercs rise up and challenge people
at the competitive level which honestly
shocked to the community that you could
be that good and compete with mouse and
keyboard players yeah they came straight
over top using that you know there's
probably a glider they get right in the
balcony there it is whoa Ryan gets
completely caught off guard
[Applause]
what just happened right there is raised
but even by the time the world cup came
around controller players they were the
outliers but ladies and gentlemen ever
there's no way anyone beats him champion
[Applause]
[Music]
but not anymore this past weekend in the
fortnight Championship Series
Invitational the top six players in na
West were on control and in na East
there was just one non controller player
in the entire top five it's actually
gotten so bad that some of the top
players in the world are trying to
reteach themselves the game on
controller to get this aim assist
advantage okay so at this point you're
probably sitting there asking yourself
like Keith isn't aim assist in like
every controller game ever how could it
possibly be having this big of an effect
on for tonight well for tonight is a
little different right now and different
from most games just in general a check
of that to me there are three main
reasons this is going on first is pretty
simple that magnetism I talked about
it's just a little too good in for that
if I get triple headshot Oh with an OGG
one more [ __ ] time I'm gonna break my
monitor second Epic Games decided to
vault traps which used to be a mechanic
and an item in fortnight that really
helped stop people from jumping in your
box you know they would shoot the wall
with an SMG jump in and try to shotgun
you you put a track on the wall it would
kill them and then you would move on and
that was a good way for mouse and
keyboard players to stop controller
players from taking advantage of aim
assist and jumping in their box but
without that they're free to just jump
on in
no well don't wig what do they comb I
gotta [ __ ] control your soul P bro
look at that [ __ ] dude
I'm like 100 and [ __ ] 30 and triple
dings me dude the last is time to kill
this isn't pro Call of Duty guys you
can't just kill someone in 10 seconds at
the highest level build fights can last
like three minutes so when I'm on
controller and I have Amos cyst and I
can hit those cheeky little shotgun
shots over the builds then my mouse and
keyboard opponent they have a little
less health they might have to shield up
faster how about a huge advantage in the
fight so with all this in mind let me
tell you the competitive scene is pissed
most notably T Fuu who feels like he's
been complaining about aim assist for
like a calendar year at this point not
only our controller players dominant but
the way they're dominant just kind of
sucks
so people are cranky about it including
as usual ninja who responded to the
outcry on Twitter with this video
controller aim-assist is more you know
it's performing way better than it does
on Xbox and Playstation and [ __ ] when
you're on PC I see a lot of players
obviously even Aiden and a couple others
are you know talking about how it is
extremely broken is extremely
overpowered right now this is just the
standard though right [ __ ] goes down the
big names complain they get their views
on Twitter same old same old but the
most staggering reaction to all of this
is from the controller players the ones
benefiting from all of this who also
think that a misis needs a massive nerf
you know when guys like scoped a guy
who's become one of the best players in
the world on the sticks in the last year
says that Amos this is too much it's
probably time to take notice look if you
ask me aim assist existing is a good
thing the fact that you can battle on
other controller or BIOS and keyboard in
games like apex legends games like
four-night and games like warzone is
actually really cool and it also makes
this whole eSports thing a lot more
appealing to that 12 year old kid
sitting on his couch with a controller
in his hands playing PlayStation but I
also get the other side of it it feels
bad that some random Punk can pick up a
controller and
shoot you out of the air like he's a
sicko at the game after one day of
playing and that's pretty much exactly
what trav said I do get your point
though because like no random schmuck
can just pick up a mouse and keyboard
and do some what well they're gonna suck
and they're gonna suck a lot but if you
grab like a controller there is a chance
that it will kind of just assist you in
some situations you know so now with all
that in mind there are others that stand
on the other side of this debate and say
that no matter what no matter how hard
developers try the mouse and keyboard
and controller and aim assist will never
be conducive to a healthy eSports
environment and that in some cases like
fortnight the fact that aim assist
exists is holding them back from being
the competitive game that they maybe
could be I know you need a missus with
controller I know you do
I get that but [ __ ] it's not viable PC
mouse and keyboard and controller
competing against each other it's just
[ __ ] not I have to pull down the
compensate they just have to put their
cross in the right spot now to end off
this subject I think it's important to
say that Epic Games has acknowledged
that this is a problem or at the very
least they say that on their next patch
after the fmcs Invitational ends this
weekend they're going to be addressing
controllers and aim-assist now before I
leave you with this subject I should say
that epic games they say they're going
to address controllers on their next set
of patch notes that comes after the FNC
s invitational finishes off this weekend
so maybe we'll have it you know maybe a
little nerf aim-assist controllers and
mouse and keyboard players will finally
be equal and we'll see really who the
best fortnight player is if we start
playing fortnight our viewers are not
gonna be happy these kids these guys
hate for nothing look guys it's fun okay
it's a fun game some it's okay to play
games that are fun even if they are not
the peak level of competition with
consistent spray patterns fortnight and
csgo are both good in their own rights